c'est là où j'ai passé honteusement des
heures cachées recroquevillé à jouer en
cash et et à me cacher dans la dans la
seine dans un mini placard où il y avait
la chaudière comme aujourd'hui encore
quand je joue au jeu je crie très fort
je pense que la personne n'en suis plus
fier dans ma vie c'est mon petit frère
quoi j'étais parmi les premiers j'ai eu
trop de chance je suis un peu faible
cieux sur mes jambes parce que je me dis
fou s'agit d'un gros truc là qu'on
balance
[Musique]
l'épicentre est
mais dans la rue de mon enfance on est à
anthony et j'ai tourné plein de trucs
dans cette rue juste là bas j'ai tourné
plein de vidéos dans cette rue il y
avait un défi de squeeze où je me
connais des tartes des tartes haché pas
quoi dans la tête parce que j'ai un pote
qui a vu une moto moi j'étais assez
injuste et assez introverti j'étais ni
le gars qui se fait saquer un peu ni le
gars classe du lycée j'étais le gt
l'invisible tu vas ou pas
j'avais mon groupe de potes j'étais bien
on rentrait en geek et ont kiffé on est
par contre j'étais pas très studio quoi
j'avais un gros souci avec l'école
c'était pas trop mon délire geagea des
cours que j'adorais mais j'arrivais
vraiment pas à me concentrer plus de dix
minutes donc j'adorerais pendant pendant
10 minutes j'étais à fond et d'un coup
mon cerveau lâché je n'arrivais pas à me
concentrer
ma mère c'était très fait des études
fins et très là les craintes d'une mère
qui veut le mieux pour son fils en fait
et qui du coup lui diraient les jeux
c'est nocif pour toi ton addiction faut
que tu la contrôler travail à l'école
soit studieux fait de grandes études
c'est ce schéma là que je comprends
totalement avec tous les parents ont en
fait parce qu'ils veulent le mieux pour
leurs enfants et le mieux c'est la
sécurité et mon père c'était un peu lui
il est un peu artiste dans l'âme il et
il adore la bd il adore prendre les
photos et en fait ils adorent les gens
qui ont des passions en fait et quand il
a vu du coût que j'avais une passion
pour les vidéos
lui il était vraiment la basique yves
asia font des toits les moyens en fait
ouais je faisais vraiment ça pour faire
quelque chose en fait
et pas pour j'étais pas dans l'attenté
de quelque chose je le faisais parce que
ça me faisait plaisir
après effectivement je batte mentir
quand j'ai quand j'ai commencé à faire
ce en vue de sang vu 300 vue mille
abonnés c'était incroyable j'étais
l'agent wahou mais qui se passe mais il
n'y avait pas d'attendre particulière et
je pense c'est ce qui différencie
d'ailleurs la première génération de
youtube heures et toutes les autres
c'est que tous les gars n'avait aucune
attente ils ont juste et c'était un truc
par pure passion lui ça va excuse moi je
mets mon mât c'est parce qu'on tournait
t'inquiète pas tu veux si tu as françois
furet tu es au lycée maintenant aïe aïe
aïe
bien sûr j'étais bien j'étais à des
quatre mois grâce à ça fait plaisir
français bien de chez nous ouais ça
vient de chez vous les gars
c'est grave qu'elle discute merci ça
fait plaisir tu as quel âge toi là tu es
en seconde ou première
il faut travailler attention on essaye
je sais je sais combien truc que je dis
qu'on me dit mais comment tu as fait
comment tu as fait pour avoir des
abonnés tôt jeudi juste
m j'étais parmi les premiers j'ai eu
trop de chance c'est tout c'est le seul
vrai avantage dont j'ai connaissance et
celui là c'est d'avoir été parmi les
premiers c'est assez incroyable tu fais
des trucs pas dingue mais y'a rien à
côté donc les gens vont se satisfaire de
ce truc pas dingue puisqu'à rien d'un
côté regarde
ceci dit j'ai toujours tendance à à
chier sur le passé sur ce que je faisais
ou ce que j'ai été dans le passé par les
évoquer du passé à chaque fois je vais
un peu le tirer vers le bas le rabaisser
le jeu pas pourquoi je travaille sur ça
en ce moment
mais tu es mon psy en fait et s'ils ont
quitté ce pain pour enfants on va aller
au studio cyprien gaming le tout premier
qui est dans le 10e arrondissement de
paris rue des petites écuries c'est la
rue où se trouve où se trouvait le
studio suprin gaming au moment où on a
commencé sur un gaming et on est resté
ici deux ans et demi quand même cyprien
il m'a contactée sur twitter 2013 m'a
rapidement envoyé un message pour me
dire salut mec j'ai un projet dont
j'aimerais te parler est ce que tu es et
ce que tu es 10.2 c4 et on s'est
retrouvé dans un starbucks à odéon et
c'était vers le mot de passe de la
chaîne seringues aimé me prendre deux
ans c'était starbucks odéon j'espère que
six places et pâtes et mot de passe pour
d'autres choses sinon t'es un peu comme
j'ai dit à ma mère et j'ai un an
d'avancé j'ai eu mon bac l'a donc tu me
donnes une année ma mère est née du ok
pas de souci bonne chance et voilà on
est sûr brut aujourd'hui j'étais très
timide au début on là là et ça se voit
j'étais nerveux un peu j'étais pas hyper
à l'aise en plus on était dans un la
base eux et ils font pas du tout
électrique de youtube heures et donc du
coup j'étais un endroit où on tournait
dans l'accueil des bureaux où c'est un
espèce de salon mais qui est pas du tout
faits pour ça donc on avait mis un
canapé une table télé avec une télé pour
pouvoir tourner et du coup il y avait
plein de passage pendant qu'on tournait
elle et c'était super intimidant pour
moi puisque wanaram en jeu tourner seul
dans ma chambre
de préférence quand les personnes à la
maison donc j'étais dedans
en fait si pris un au delà d'avoir été
un tremplin de visibilité démentiel il
m'a vraiment pris sous son aile
il ya vraiment une relation un peu grand
frère petit frère pendant très longtemps
moi j'étais jeune j'avais 17 ans tout ça
c'était très nouveau pour moi j'étais je
sortais pas énormément quand j'étais
plus jeune donc je connaissais très peu
le monde des adultes et encore moins le
monde du travail
ce que j'avais juste mon bac et lui m'a
tout de suite
ouais pris sous son aile il m'a appris à
la fois plein de choses pour les vidéos
plein de choses dans le perso plein de
choses pour ma vie personnelle en tant
que lucas quand on a fait supprimer mais
moi j'avais dit à cyprien bon c'est cool
comme ça je vais fermer ma chaîne perso
moi et je vais pouvoir dégager du temps
pour d'autres trucs
ces crédits ou là qu'est ce que tu as
dit luca pendant trois ans j'ai monté
tout mes vidéos trouver les idées
tourner tout fait tout seul
et du coup j'arrive et un peu la
saturation puisque jamais un rythme
assez énervé quoi et cyprien m'a dit non
mais mec continue ta chaîne et prend un
monteur démontage tu les fais faire par
un ou plusieurs personnes est comme ça
ça va dégager du temps et tout ensuite
je pourrai te concentrer sur qu'est ce
tu as fait remonter prochaine vidéo sur
telle vie perso sur tout ça et ça a été
un très bon conseil on est dans mes
nouveaux bureaux
tout fraîchement acquis il ya eu des
travaux là il ya pas mal de bob qui ont
été montées ça avance je suis très
content ici c'est pas moi c'est yoko je
faisais pas prévenu fait du bruit
[Musique]
c'est brut je vous ai pas prévenu comme
un micro ce n'est jamais arrivé je pense
qu'on n'a jamais été aussi sa casquette
merci brut je pense que la personne en
chine plus fier dans ma vie c'est mon
petit frère quoi parce qu'il a suivi sa
voie
parce qu'il accompli bien de choses
parce que je pense que c'est malgré tout
ce qui s'est passé et toutes les choses
qui doit gérer
je pense que c'est resté une personne
qui est très quand même qu'à un
pied-à-terre qui a quel sens des
responsabilités qui est très humaine
quoi travaillez bien mon état je
préférais évidemment pourquoi parce que
c'est le mien c'est la voyais mon studio
justice est faux tu peux pas voir tu
peux pas avoir dimanche je montre le
studio dans une vidéo et du coup je suis
désolé brut mais pour le moment ces
zones privées en revanche
mettez vous à l'aise direction la
terrasse à l'on dit je trouve que
j'étais tellement tout le temps dans le
tas fait j'y vais tellement que par ça
parce que j'adorais créé krékré faire
des trucs faire un truc fait un truc les
donner aux gens et de nogent et donne
aux gens que j'ai un peu trop délaissé
le perso la famille
l'amoureuse des amis et c'est je me suis
beaucoup posé des questions à ce sujet
il ya des phases comme ça on est traître
et a fait je pense que le mieux c'est
d'être équilibrés sur tout ça voilà
mais c'est dur puisque d'un autre côté
j'ai envie de faire plein de choses
parce que le temps passe et j'aurais pas
toujours l'opportunité de faire plein de
choses
quand j'ai annoncé que j'avais fait un
album et de la musique du coup de bol en
fait annoncer un album ça veut dire
juste ok les gars les musiques de les
faire en trois heures je vais en faire
14 mai en un an je vais te raconter des
trucs j'ai peut-être en tout cas je vais
m'investir c'est pour moi il veut dire
ça ce mot album qu'est ce que je ferais
écouter j'étais dégoûté le mais après je
le dis partout c'est pas grave mais je
le dit partout que ce sont là c'est mon
préféré que j'adore et que c'est pas
grave il me dit non de la tête
derrière c
c'est
[Musique]
c'est un son sur ben on en parlait tout
à l'heure à anthony n'est ce pas sur ma
relation avec ma mère et que j'ai écrit
dans l'avion au tour du japon on avait
une résidence de trois semaines là-bas
pour avancer beaucoup sur l'album à
grands pas et se consacrer qu'à ça et
ouais dans l'avion en fait je m'étais
dit [ __ ] j'ai je suis pas sûr d'avoir
dit à ma mère que j'étais au japon et du
coup ça m'a fait pas d je me suis dit
mais c'est pas normal de ne pas avoir
prévenu sa mère qui ont eu la peau
pendant trois semaines donc du coup j'ai
fait son est celui dont je suis
particulièrement fier et au moment où je
te parle maintenant on l'a pas entendu
encore j'aimerais bien lui faire écouter
devant moi ce split marrant caisses du
destin écoute et kiev à ça tu parles du
savoureuse
elle passe complètement à côté de son
horrible je crois que j'idolâtre et je
me prenais beaucoup la tête je me disais
vraiment les gens qui font la musique
sont pas comme le commun des mortels
ils sont ils sont au dessus ils sont
comment dire ils sont traités sont
charismatiques tu vois un artiste un
gars qui fait que de la musique tu me
connais 4 rca music tu dis douala de
vachement tu mythifie il est très
charismatique et où c'est un peu
intimidant quoi et en fait quand tu
crèves l'aps et que tu les rencontrer
que tu leur parles tu fais mes attentes
mais en fait c'est des humains comme moi
qui ont des passions comme moi gens qui
ont beaucoup d'expérience qui sont dans
ce milieu et qui s'ouvre à toi vraiment
les écouter esther et moi qui parle
beaucoup quand admirer me parler je ne
parlais pas j'écoute et je notais dans
un coin de ma tête j'étais ok ok attend
près de faire ton du numéro tu veux
qu'on s'a du mal quand je le conçois
la musique c'est vraiment un truc en
plus et en aucun cas une porte de sortie
ou un avenir différent un truc c'est les
vidéos cd live et j'aurai besoin de ça
toute ma vie même là quand je tombe
pendant trois semaines même un petit
truc tu vois une petite vidéo un petit
regret dit un petit truc je suis ça me
fait trop bizarre parce que ce que j'ai
fait jusqu'à présent c'est ce que j'aime
le plus au monde dont je remplace que
jamais tout ça